how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and today
we have another update for
the eternals trailer but this time we
also have some news about the wanda
vision series and the falcon and the
winter soldier series as well
a few days ago we got a report saying
that we could be getting something for
the eternals relatively soon possibly
within the next few weeks
now this came from a pretty reliable
source a source that has been right
about trailer releases in the past
but in his initial report he said that
he didn't know whether it was a teaser
trailer or if it was just some footage
in general or something else
however recently he has updated his
report and he has confirmed
what he heard about was the official
teaser trailer for
the eternals so whatever we have coming
up for the eternals whenever it gets
released it will in fact be a teaser
trailer giving us
our very first look at the eternals what
everybody's going to look like what the
feel of the movie is going to be like
and maybe they'll even give us a little
bit of a tease of what the eternals were
doing during all of the avengers
events kevin feige the president of
marvel studios has said
that this film will address what the
eternals were doing
during all these events because their
job is to protect the earth they're
supposed to protect earth and the humans
so where exactly were they during the
events of avengers infinity war avengers
endgame where were they when thanos
attacked where were they when
ultron almost destroyed the planet and
where were they for things like
hydra and loki attacking in the first
avengers film maybe the teaser trailer
will tease us a little bit of
where they were maybe even show some
previous mcu characters
so this is a great update but he had
more to update us about
and real quick if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things relating to the mcu and so you
can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a dr doom funko pop just subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below so the source that told us and
updated us about the eternals teaser
trailer has now recently dropped some
more news
and he says as per his source there
could be much more other stuff as well
alongside the eternals
footage and he went on to say that the
source did say that there could be more
so who knows if it's one division or any
other disney plus thing like star wars
related now if we take a step back
we can see that it would actually make a
lot of sense for marvel to start
releasing
teaser trailers for certain films and
projects marvel has always attended san
diego comic con's
hall age panel it's pretty much the
biggest event of the year for marvel
fans and unfortunately due to covet 19
they're doing a comic-con
at home and marvel studios will not be
attending but marvel
does know that many many fans were
waiting and very excited about comic con
at home because they were expecting some
things to be released from marvel or any
type of news about the future at all
now dc isn't attending comic-con at home
either but they are doing their own
fandom event an exclusive dc event where
they're going to talk about all the new
stuff they have coming up now marvel
might not necessarily do this but
marvel has something that dc doesn't
that is
disney and disney owns many different
things many different tv stations
and the nba is starting up in the next
couple of weeks and as i mentioned in a
previous video marvel has been known to
leverage professional sports games to
premiere their trailers
in fact the super bowl is usually a
pretty big event for marvel they usually
release a new trailer for a film they
have coming up
and we've heard from many different
reports by now that the wanda vision
teaser trailer
is ready to go and so is the falcon in
the winter soldier teaser trailer and it
does seem like marvel is planning
something even if it isn't their own
event it does seem like they're ready to
blow out new trailers
last week it was confirmed that there
are two new black widow trailers that
are supposed to be released relatively
soon so they have a lot of trailers on
deck that they're ready to show to the
public the only question
is when are they going to do this well
based off of everything that we've heard
or haven't heard such as we haven't
heard anything about marvel doing their
own event
it seems like they're going to start
releasing trailers during the return of
professional sports
and based off of everything that we've
heard the trailers they have lined up
are the eternals trailer
two new black widow trailers the wanda
vision teaser trailer and the falcon and
the winter soldier
teaser trailer now keep in mind the
first look that we got at the one
division series the falcon and the
winter soldier series and the loki
series were during the super bowl they
weren't their own
personal teaser trailers they were more
like a marvel studios disney plus teaser
trailer the big
game spot but they gave us our first
look and it seems like marvel is
planning to do that
again but this time when the nba
restarts and they already have a plan
with the nba players to show them the
actual black widow film
so when the nba starts they're going to
be seeing the actual black widow film so
clearly marvel is making moves with the
nba
so from what it sounds like right now
marvel studios
is planning on releasing some of these
teaser trailers during commercials
during their professional sports
primarily the nba
so it's not just the eternals teaser
trailer that is coming but apparently
the one division teaser could be coming
soon
along with the falcon and the winter
soldier teaser as well and based off of
everything that we've heard it seems
pretty likely so
let me know in the comments down below
which trailer you are excited the most
about to see
let me know which one in the comments
down below don't forget to like this
video and subscribe to stay up to date
on
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe for live updates you
can follow
me on twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof